you know a society can hit low points we
can hit the hit the depths of our
biorhythm and still go back up I'm
optimistic Tim I'm always optimistic
because I you know there's something
about Americans
there's something about our Constitution
and these are unique and they are
special and I I just I just feel in my
heart and maybe I'm crazy and stupid and
maybe I'm idealistic God help me I
thought that was
surgically removed from me in law school
but I think we come back from this but
it's important that we understand how
far down we are it's like the alcoholic
has to take you know inventory when he
hits bottom but during uh would you say
that during the Vietnam era the country
was at this level of
authoritarianism no fracturing political
tribalism uh somewhat remember there was
a full-scale terrorist low intensity low
intensity uh uh uh conflict thousands of
bombings in the early 70s thousands in
the early 70s I mean they weren't
killing people left and right but they
were kind of killing people left it was
mostly shock and awe wasn't it a lot of
it was uh a lot of it were message
bombings but there were you know cops
being shot down in the street uh the
capital was blown up uh they tried to
blow up a number of targets managed to
blow up themselves which you know that's
a win-win
um
unfortunately after after that a lot of
them were absorbed into Academia
and uh look we and then raised some kids
who wanted to become DA's in San
Francisco yes Chessa Bodine we
um
what we need
what look
here's what I'm afraid of and here's
what we need we need
not Ronald Reagan but a reagan-like
figure who is willing to come in and
push his agenda towards the kind of uh
civil rights civil liberties that we're
talking about not exactly like Ronald
Reagan not the same policies but a a
communicator who is forthright and
focused
I am worried that what we're going to
get is a real authoritarian because
people are going to say I can't take
this chaos that's right I can't take
this chaos
there are three options a free Society
where everyone has rights a society
where our authoritarian rules a society
where they're authoritarian rules I want
number one I can live with number two
number three it's war was Abraham
Lincoln authoritarian yes that's right
he was yes he was and he was one of my
heroes he he his pick portrait was on my
family's wall at my grandmother's house
uh in Chambersburg Pennsylvania burned
twice by A Confederacy right down the
road from Gettysburg which is one of the
first places I was taken as a kid so yes
a guy can be authoritarian and not
necessarily
authoritarian in context and in a
limited way with the idea of coming back
from it James Buchanan right he was the
one who led us into uh the Civil War
basically yeah he was uh the uh Biden of
his era exactly well that's what I was
going to say is Biden Buchanan jbjb jbj
oh no except I'm not sure
I'm not sure Buchanan was uh you know
Grandpa Badfinger but let's leave this
person can we can we get like a
numerologist now to like do the numbers
and be like the correlation between the
two well let me let me let me text my
phrenologist there you go see what he's
so so a lot of people were wondering if
this period of Biden would be so bad
that you will get a major you know
blowout election in 2022 and 2024 with
your will
I mean I'd like to say that but I think
I've thought that in the past
you know in 2018 I was like wow I was
like with how crazy the Democrats have
gotten and how inconsistent and broken
and then we get the squad are you
actually get more uh absurd look the
Democrat party has been pulled to the
left the uh Republican party has been
pulled uh to the Patriotic uh because
for a long time the Republican party was
you know an establishment party it was
the party of the guy who pulled up and
uh uh you know stepped out of his
limousine and fired all you guys uh who
worked at the uh Carrier air
conditioning plant and said hey your
job's going to Oaxaca don't worry we'll
uh teach you to code or something and he
looks exactly like Mitt Romney by the
way
and look the Republican Party ignored
normal people the guys who built this
country fed it fueled it fought for it
they ignored them
in in in favor of this giant corporate
nightmare I look you you got to
understand I was a normal Republican I I
subscribed to the Weekly Standard before
it became you know uh legally anti-trump
before it became a Jeffrey tube and uh
uh Zoom inspiration material
um
and I I I only change because of YC I
was not a supporter of trump when he was
running
uh before he ran before he won the
Primary after he won the Primary I was a
reluctant supporter I became an active
supporter when he proved himself I I
supported going into Iraq I support
going into Afghanistan I thought these
were good ideas I actually participated
in a successful nation building
operation Kosovo very different
situation though
I changed my mind speak my mind because
the facts changed and I love what these
guys on Twitter like you know in a 10
years ago you had different ideas yes
yes when when things changed and I I
reevaluated under new facts yes I
changed my mind you you have correctly
assessed what I have done good point
Aces you are correct and I don't delete
the old stuff oh yeah several years ago
I didn't own any guns now I own many oh
now I got a bear at M82 nice I think
that's right holy crap what do you got
Bears around here yeah actually that
that's not for Bears
I mean it could happen well Bears
daddies you know otters yeah so but uh
uh no it's it's you have a I I went I
remember I was talking to someone who
posted on Facebook some meme like
there's no reason to own any weapon they
said no no self-respecting Hunter
whatever he was an assault weapon and so
then uh I was not a hunter I responded
with like showing like you know a
polymer tip uh 450 Bushmaster versus
like a nine millimeter which is used in
combat or like a five five six and then
I'm like which one do you think the
hunter uses they use the stopping power
for large animals and I was like your
argument makes no sense but the
interesting thing was they came back
with like oh the right wing gun nuts no
one's taking your guns here's a list of
my guns that have been banned already
and like and and then he responded with
would you need any of those for and so I
actually said I'm gonna engage with this
guy in good faith and I had a list I
said okay and then I explained the
purpose of every gun like barrel length
caliber like hunting a small game like I
got a break action 410 it's like a
turkey shot you know what I mean because
we have wild turkeys sometimes we don't
really we don't use it here but when you
go to West Virginia you gotta get rid of
some of the turkeys because there are
pests if there's too many then you gotta
then you get something more powerful if
there's wild boars investing an area
deer can become a very big problem yep
and then you have home defense you've
got different uh you know options there
and then I was like we'll put the M82 at
the bottom we'll come back to that one
later and then I said and then and then
my response to that one was because I
have a right to own it and it's none of
your business yeah because outside of
anything else I can easily explain the
function of these things this one it's
just it's mine yeah I I want which is
another grounds for not taking the
vaccine why don't you want the vaccine
because I don't
argument over that
they don't understand about rights to
him they think that rights are just uh
like a brand of like special privilege
but if you you know you know if you have
a really good reason though the right
has to give way and as I I said before a
lot of these people have the whole
rights responsibility thing like uh was
his name Uncle Ben and Spider-Man with
great power comes great responsibility
no no the the idea of Rights is no
responsibility rights are a given
otherwise they're not rights they're
just Privileges and we've seen what you
would do with privileges the founding
fathers said that we have uh you know
it's self-evident we have we have
inalienable rights that were granted to
us by our creator yes we can do them
even if you think it's a bad idea and
they'll try and stop you yes and even
with the Constitution and the Bill of
Rights they still infringe upon all of
them even though the founding fathers
outlined that these shall not be
infringed but here we are and one of the
biggest disasters of our uh institutions
is the Supreme Court failing to
aggressively police attacks on our
rights every time they pass on a uh you
know you can't sing in church
the Supreme Court is meaningless the
Supreme Court would have had some moral
Authority if it stood up for the things
it should then people would listen now
people are like well you know Kavanaugh
is just going to roll over because he's
got to go to the country club a guy I
don't understand because if they did
that to me holy crap it would be a Jihad
so they would be my project I think it
was Will Chamberlain told us that the
reason the Supreme Court doesn't get
aggressive on some of these cases is
because they have no enforcement ability
and if they push hard on something it
will reveal the emperor has no clothes
which it has when the Supreme Court
ruled that the eviction moratoriums were
illegal completely in every sense and
the CDC has no authority to do it then
Biden said
there's no way yeah whatever screw the
Supreme Court that's my my issue with
rights being inalienable I mean the way
it's written is they can't anybody can't
can't be taken away they're there but
like the reality like that's kind of the
myth we tell ourselves the reality is if
someone with a lot of weapons wants to
just say this is a new world with new
sets of rights and laws and ideas then
that is what it is well simply because
rights can be violated doesn't make them
not right it makes somebody a violator
of Rights and you have a moral
obligation to resist no no right look
people are going to want to take what's
yours you may also but they're going to
want to take in do you think people have
a right to express themselves really it
depends on the situation so that's is
that a no yeah if you're if you're out
in the woods and if you make a sound the
the panther knows where you are and will
rip your throat out then no you don't
you don't have that right
you have the ability you have the right
you just gotta defend it right which is
why you need that Bushmaster but I mean
the reality is we're squishy bodies but
I don't think you understand what a
right means right so exactly we've got
to Define what that means if if somebody
wanted to speak freely should they be
stopped
well it depends on the situation if
you're going to alert that they're your
presence then yeah they should be
stopped well I'm just saying like Okay
so there are circumstances which you
think people should be allowed to
express themselves yes right I don't I
don't agree with that I think people
have a right to express themselves no
matter what well the concept of the
military the consequences are their
choice
there's a difference between saying well
you might give away your position it's
like okay well you're allowed to do it
that's your decision not mine and I'll
tell you this and if I'm standing next
to you and we're in the woods and you
want to start screaming with have your
lungs I have a right to walk away and
I'll say Ian you go ahead and do it was
going to get us killed then
I will leave no my your my rights are
more important than your life and it's
not even close and no offense but my
rights are more important than your
they're also more important than my life
I will not live where I cannot speak
freely where I cannot worship as I see
fit I will not live that one what about
the right I will die before I do what
about the right to pursue happiness
that's not a right that's that is this
that is a that that is a a preamble
rights are specific
Liberty in the pursuit of happiness yes
and that was a that was like a
conveyance of feeling about what their
goal was not they didn't they didn't
make the First Amendment the right to
pursue happiness yes nebulous and vague
and can't be enforced yes and and the
Bill of Rights is not the only rights it
simply expects some in fact they thought
many many people thought we don't need a
Bill of Rights of stuff it's obvious
well thank you it was the
Anti-Federalists I don't remember as
well I think it was the Anti-Federalists
were like ah we're not giving you that
power it's got to be outlined in fact I
think there was originally 17 in the
Bill of Rights and they decided to
combine some remove some and boy did
they screw up the second you know why
because the original article that they
wrote up actually said even if you are
not a part of a militia your right to
keep in bear arms shall not be infringed
but they were worried that if they
included that people would use it as an
argument to avoid conscription
so they said let's just say you have the
right that's just let's just give the uh
damn Brady group of uh some to try and
hang it stupid it doesn't it doesn't
matter though you know why because
without still clear without culture it's
meaningless oh of course that's my point
rights have to be look rights have to be
defended enforced but no no Ian I'm not
saying that your rights don't exist I'm
saying that if you don't have a culture
that's willing that's going to agree
with you or recognize your rights then
the Constitution the Constitution
doesn't grant you your rights it tells
the government not to infringe upon
these specific rights right but if you
have a culture that says will infringe
anyway be prepared to defend it but it
was the the fathers the founding fathers
that decided which rights are
inalienable now no no no no no no no no
no no it wasn't like God no they handled
it for now no they didn't in they said
let's create a list of rights to stop
the government from infringing they even
say that rights that aren't included are
not are just because they didn't include
in the Bill of Rights it doesn't mean
you don't have those rights right they
were like let's pick the best like out
Puritan Christian white men that agreed
on a set of Rights well does it mean
that they're the only rights or that
they're the best rights no Ian you are
wrong they didn't all agree on what
rights were in fact there was an
argument over whether or not they'd have
a Bill of Rights what they said was we
have rights then which ones do we put in
out of 17 they get down to 10 and they
said these are the ones that protect the
country and they negotiated and
compromised there were many people who
felt there were some rights you should
have and some right you shouldn't have
some people were were slave owners and
some people were abolitionists they
clearly did not agree
I guess some cultures might have a Bill
of Rights that say you have the right to
three wives yeah but they're wrong well
who says though
our constitution does not say you have a
right to anything
yes that's correct no positive right it
does it says no these these rights are
yours
right and the government are right
cannot infringe our rights are negative
rights the rights that the enumerated
rights that is the ones are specifically
set out because those are not the only
ones they're specifically Reserve other
rights the enumerated rights are all
negative the Bill of Rights the Bill of
Rights they are all negative in the
sense that they uh the government cannot
infringe on these there are no rights
that you have to something you have no
right to a house or a job or to my labor
but in certain pronouns in saying they
have the obligation to not infringe on
that right they're essentially saying
you have that right yeah so they're
acknowledging no that well the brights
come from God that's what it says it's
written in that it's like God come on
guys I don't think you understand the
philosophy yeah I think it'd be really
important that if you're going where
else would rights come from you're done
Ian you need to actually like read some
Theology and some religion to understand
what they're saying because I think the
problem here is that you fundamentally
don't understand the philosophy behind
inalienable rights you seem to think
that some guys write a Bible and just
arbitrarily decided something because
you don't understand what it means to
have intrinsic inherent value well I see
that there is value to it I acknowledge
like the free speech is legit but it's
also subjective to our society and our
culture right now now I can't a right
can't be subjective or right is inherent
to every human being and you know even
even the victim of the Taliban who's got
an AK-47 to his head has a right to
speak freely even if someone's going to
blow his head off because he does it uh
and when I say the rights come from God
I look look I'm a religious guy there
are people who aren't religious who just
unders who are humanists they'll call
themselves humanists and say that as a
human being I have these rights and you
know at the end the the effect is uh
similar in that they are a given they
are outside debate you cannot debate the
right to do it because the rate exists
that's why I reject all these balancing
tests well you know Tim it's important
that you have Free Speech but you know
if your speech is harmful well look
speech is the only speech that matters
the only time rights matter is when it's
harmful or forbidden or unwanted or
unreasonable otherwise it doesn't you
don't need a right
you know no one will care there's there
are certain rights that are actually
Universal in fact
um you know uh in all in all cultures
you know well I there are basic like
tenets that allow us to survive as a
species better and I think a lot of
those are codified in the US
Constitution but for people to realize
the reason I'm bringing this up is
because I'm afraid that people are going
to rely and be like these are my rights
this paper says so so no one can touch
me and like dude you have to fight yeah
if you want those to be realized you
need to struggle we're on the same sheet
of music there and that's you know
that's that's why I believe every
American should own guns that's why I
believe every American should be uh
trained to participate in the defense of
our community and Constitution
I mean there's the serious challenge
though of what happens when the bus
pulls up for the Australians and says
you know we're going to be taking you
and relocating you to the alternative
quarantine Hub to the relocatable
campsite we're going to be color
coordinating you know your outfits and
your and your and your uh cabins
unfortunately they're going to finish
their Fosters and get on board then
actually I don't think they have Fosters
in Australia I think they found I don't
think so no I think it's like I think
it's like the uh the old Milwaukee no
I'm pretty sure it's not there I have
friends from Australia and they're like
we don't have that you don't have
Fosters
yeah I'm pretty sure that's not Sydney
Watson yeah she said they were from
Australia I always make that joke uh or
not a half joke to my Australian friends
I'd be like oh so you guys like drink
Fox Fosters like Budweiser like we don't
have that's American
and I'd be like really really okay but
maybe thanks for checking out this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast if you want
to see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time